[Music]
Coco is such an emotional movie but when
you look deeper into it there are a lot
of little things that make you wonder
stay tuned for a theory that could
change the whole meaning of the film are
you new around here don't forget to give
this video a big thumbs up and subscribe
to the things for more great content
like this now on to ten Koko theories
that will leave you shook evil people
get remembered if you haven't seen Koko
then we are sorry for all of the
spoilers that we are about to throw your
way
but seriously what have you been doing
all this time go watch the movie if you
have seen the movie then you know the
premise of the film basically in the
film you can only exist in the afterlife
as long as someone remembers you so
naturally people only remain in the
afterlife and tell their families pass
away and then they disappear in theory
it makes sense
how long can one person really be
remembered well not long if you're a
regular person but this one theory had a
super spooked the only people that are
remembered for centuries are famous
people people like Michael Jackson
George Washington and a Madonna but
there is also a flip side to that coin
history's worst people will also be
remembered in the same way people like
Hitler for instance would be in the
afterlife for the rest of eternity it
makes you think if cocoa got it right
then that means that by teaching the
ugly parts of history we would be
helping to keep history's worst people
in the afterlife
isn't that awful to think about same
universe as other films have you heard
of the Pixar theory it's the idea that
all of Pixar's movies actually take
place in the same universe so instead of
taking each movie for a singular story
you can see it as interwoven with the
rest of the movies and the Pixar family
cocoa fits perfectly into this ideal in
the film people need their family
members to remember them or else they
experience the final death and disappear
forever the same is true and inside-out
when Riley forgets her imaginary friend
Bing bong he also fades away it
disappears in both films the characters
need someone to remember them to stay
alive so it makes sense that these
stories would take place in the same
universe and memory isn't just important
when it comes to staying alive it's also
very important another way
for instance a big theme in The
Incredibles is that mr. incredible
doesn't want people to forget about him
or all of the good that he's done he's
afraid that you will disappear from
their memories if all of these movies
took place in the same universe then
it's safe to assume that these
characters probably ran into each other
at some point wouldn't it be insane
Hector and Ernesto spoiler alert we are
about to get into a major spoiler so if
you haven't seen the film pause this
video go watch Coco and come back okay
now that all those people are gone we
can tell you one of the theories that
freaked us out the most so you know how
Miguel spends a lot of the movie looking
for Delacruz because he believes that he
is his grandfather it turns out that it
is actually Hector who is his
grandfather and not Ernesto but one
redditor posted to the fan theories
subreddits that they think that arnesto
and Hector might actually be the same
person just remembered in two different
ways maybe the way that people are
remembered actually creates different
versions of them in the afterlife one
version of dela Cruz is the one who gave
up a life of Fame to go back to his
family while the other one is the one
who's stuck with his music career and
gave up his family for fortune and fame
they are both Miguel's grandfather you
were going to give me you're blushing
simply two different versions if this
theory is true that our minds are
absolutely blown it makes you have to
rethink everything the movie was
supposed to be a musical there sure is a
lot of singing that goes on in the movie
Coco the singing actually plays an
integral role in the film the main song
in the film remember me is actually how
Miguel's grandfather ends up being able
to stay in the afterlife for a bit
longer as we all know Pixar doesn't do
musicals as long as the movie company
has been around they have never produced
one musical that because Coco had so
many songs and dances it made people
wonder if Coco was originally intended
to be Pixar's very first musical
according to director Lee Unkrich the
movie was supposed to be a break out
into song musical if that had been the
case then it would have been Pixar's
first venture into the musical world
no wonder the film was jam-packed with
musical numbers we wonder what made the
producers pivot from their original idea
the only thing that could have made the
movie better was if there had been even
more to
Danette what do you think was the
reasoning behind the creators not
turning the movie into a musical let us
know in the comments don't I know you
Coco is connected to the Little
Mermaid's
have you ever watched a movie and then
thought about how similar it is to
others that you have seen before
that's pretty natural there are only so
many stories that can be told so when we
watched Coco we couldn't help but notice
a crazy resemblance to another movie
know which one we were thinking of The
Little Mermaid
think about it Miguel is sort of the
outcast of his family he thinks about
things that no one else does he's
obsessed with music even though it's
been banned by his family Ariel is the
same she thinks about humans all the
time and dreams of being a part of them
both characters leave their families to
go and follow their dreams and the
similarities don't stop there part of
the film was actually modeled after the
Little Mermaid the team behinds Coco
gained inspiration for Miguel's secret
addict by looking at Ariel's secret
treasure room they wanted to give him
the perfect place to cultivate his
musical talents and connect with his
musical hero did you notice that it is
similar to Ariel's was it giving you the
Little Mermaid flashbacks if it was the
new words crazy the film is actually are
connected so this theory checks out
Hector's appearance surprisingly the
afterlife is pretty flashy when you
close your eyes and think of what the
afterlife looks like you're probably
thinking that it is all doom and gloom
it's probably all dark and dreary in
your mind and when you watch the film
you see that it's actually quite bright
and cheerful and all of the people in it
are decked out in lavish outfits a lot
of them look like they are living better
in the afterlife and they probably did
while they were living everyone except
one person and that's Hector when you
see Hector he seems like a con artist
and that's partially because his clothes
are tattered and he looks noticeably
poorer than the rest of the people
around him some people have theories as
to why that is some people on reddit
believe that Hector's lack of funds had
to do with how he was remembered the
people who are well remembered are on a
lot of ofrendas like arnesto and Frida
they look amazing they have nice clothes
and silic attractive despite not being
alive Hector is only remembered by one
person and that person is losing her
memory which may be why he is so poorly
dressed takes place after tragedy
the afterlife is a pretty big place
there is an assortment of different
people walking around all the time
it actually kind of looks a lot like
real life right these are families old
people adults and children alike but
when you really think about it it
actually becomes quite sad of course
there should be old people in the
afterlife old people pass away all the
time so why are there so many children
there when you pass on you seem to stay
the same age that you were when you pass
so that means that all of these children
passed away in their youth one theory is
that the movie is set to have taken
place after some major tragedy that
would explain why so many young people
were in the afterlife maybe it was a
massive flood that took everyone out or
a plague of some sort we'd have to look
back at the history of Mexico to
pinpoint exactly when this movie would
take place but either way there was
definitely something that was causing so
many young people to pass we don't like
to be too long and hard about this
theory because it's super sad let's move
on to something happier he and Mama
only people in Mexico the movie focuses
on Mexico and the people that live there
but are we supposed to think that the
afterlife is country specific because it
didn't seem like there were a lot of
people from other places walking around
the afterlife
why is weird in itself but this very
even gets weirder if you're supposed to
think that there are people from other
places in the afterlife then they
probably never get to cross over on the
day of the dead in order to cross over
you have to have a picture of someone's
ofrenda it's safe to say that only
people who live in Mexico or are
familiar with Mexican culture know about
a fernanda's are even celebrate the Day
of the Dead everyone else would just
have to watch as the others cross back
over and got to spend precious time with
their family members what's even worse
is that they would have no way to tell
their families to put up an off Renda
after their past it's honestly really
sad there has to be some loophole that
people from other countries can do to
spend time with their families once a
year otherwise the afterlife would be
pretty unfair hector's walk miguel
spends a lot of time with hector
throughout the movie so we get to see a
lot of this character though we do see
him a lot you may or may not have
noticed that for part of the movie
Hector walks with a pretty bad limb
there is a pretty interesting
as to what his limp is all about and one
seen Hector introduced Miguel to his
friend teacher tone chicharrón
disappears from the afterlife because
his family and everyone that he loved
has forgotten about him how does this
connect - Hector's weird walk well
Hector really starts to walk like that
after his friend dies some people
believe that maybe Hector began using
teacher tones femur after he hurt his on
one of his attempts to cross over into
the real world and see his daughter the
reason that the femur didn't disappear
with his friend is that it is now a part
of Hector's body and not teacher tones
anymore if you look closely one of
Hector's legs is shorter than his other
leg which would make perfect sense if
this theory were true now we know that
this is super far-fetched which is why
we aren't putting all of our eggs in
this theories basket but it's pretty
interesting to think about afterlife
isn't real this brings us right into
what might be the craziest theory of
them all we are led to believe that the
place that Hector and the rest of the
older family members are in is the
afterlife many of them are afraid of
being forgotten because they don't want
to leave the afterlife all of them
except one chicharrón doesn't seem too
sad to pass on instead he sighs as if he
is finally finishing a long day what if
the afterlife that we saw in the movie
is actually a state of limbo and all of
the people are chained there by memories
of their families maybe most of them
don't even know that they're in limbo or
maybe they know but would rather live in
limbo if it means being able to go back
and see their families once a year that
would also make teach you don't react
Shinto moving on make a lot of sense
maybe he wasn't so afraid to go on
because he didn't have any family
members left to visit in the real world
anyway
this theory is super out there but it's
definitely something to think about
it changes the whole dynamic of the film
that's it for 10 Koko theories that will
leave you shook were you surprised by
anything on this list let us know in the
comments thanks for watching
[Music]